who remembers this infamous Styrofoam
container
well it sure changed me it changed my
company and it started a revelatory
journey about how adversaries can be
your best allies you know back in the
late 80s this big mech clamshell was the
symbol of a garbage crisis people were
really angry
for example thousands of students young
students around the globe were sending
letters blaming McDonald's because we
were using millions of these at that
time now new one no.1 at McDonald's knew
anything about environmentally friendly
packaging including me the last ten
years I was in charge of logistics and
truck drivers then out of nowhere my
boss comes to me and says hey we want
you to save this clamshell for the
company and lead the effort to reduce
waste within McDonald's I looked at them
and I asked them what is polystyrene but
it all sounded intriguing to me because
it brought me back to my roots you see I
grew up in the late 60s early 70s in a
time of huge social upheaval in the
United States and I was really in tune
with the protests the sit-ins the
anti-vietnam sentiment and I really felt
there's a need to question authority but
as I went into university I realized
that you know I'm not going to make a
living doing this and that whole
movement had subsided and my activist
spirit went dormant and I needed to make
a living so I got involved in the
business world so now these students
against pollution who are sending those
protest letters to McDonald's they
reminded me of myself 20 years ago
they're questioning Authority but now
I'm the man
I'm the corporate suit I'm the one
representing authorities and this new
thing was emerging called corporate
social responsibility later corporate
sustainability and now I had a chance to
make a difference so the beginning of
this journey started when McDonald's
agreed to a partnership with the
Environmental Defense Fund they were an
NGO that was founded with the principle
of sue the bastards so I'm thinking what
are they thinking about me and my team
when I first met Richard Dennison he's
the senior scientist for EDF I was very
apprehensive I thought he's a tree
hugger and I'm thinking he thinks all I
care about is the money so we wanted EDF
team to give us real-world solutions so
we did the logical thing we had them
flip burgers in our restaurants so you
have to imagine Richard who by the way
is a PhD in physics and there he is he's
trying to dress a quarter-pounder and
you're supposed to have two squirts at
ketchup one mustard three pickles on an
onion go on to the next one he got to be
so fast and you know what he couldn't
get it right all day long and he was
frustrated and I was so impressed
because he was trying to understand our
business now the EDF team they thought
reusables were the holy grail for our
business me and my team thought
reusables too much space they'd make a
mess they would slow us down but we
didn't reject the idea we went at a
restaurant that they chose outside DC we
went to the backroom the dishwasher
wasn't working properly at spitting out
dirty dishes the kitchen area is dirty
and grimy and compared to their
experience at McDonald's as clean and
organized they could see the stark
difference we also sat in a restaurant
at McDonald's all day long and watched
the customers eating in their behavior
ends up that many customers left with
the food they left with the beverage
and EDF came to their own conclusion
that reusables won't work for us but
they did have a lot of ideas that did
work and they we never would have
thought of them by ourselves without the
EDF team my favorite was switching from
the white carry out bag to the brown bag
we had been using the white bag its
virgin material it's made from chlorine
bleaching chemicals and they said use an
unbleached bag no chemicals it's made
from recycled content mostly recycled
shipping corrugated boxes ends up that
the bag is stronger the fiber is
stronger it didn't cost us more money
it was win-win another idea they had was
that we could reduce our napkin by one
inch and make it from recycled office
paper I'm thinking one inch no big deal
we did it a reduce waste by three
million pounds a year sixteen thousand
trees saved
[Applause]
what was really cool as we changed that
bright white napkin because of the
recycled content it became gray and
speckled and we made that look you know
in tune involved with customers so I
came to really enjoy the time working
with the EDF team we had many dinners
late night discussions we went to a ball
game together we became friends and
that's when I learned a life lesson that
these NGO Crusaders they're really no
different than me they care they have
passion
we're just not different so we had a
six-month partnership that ended up
producing a 42 point waste reduction
action plan to reduce reuse recycle we
measured it during the decade of the 90s
and over ten years we reduced 300
million pounds of waste now if you're
wondering about that polystyrene
clamshell yeah we ditched it and luckily
I still had a job and this partnership
was so successful that we went on to
recycle the idea with crit to work with
critics collaborate them on solutions
that could work for society and for
business but could this idea of
collaborating work with the most
contrarian folks and on issues that are
you know not within our direct control
like animal rights now animal rights
obviously they don't want animals used
for meat McDonald's probably the biggest
purchaser of meat in the foodservice
industry so there's a natural conflict
there but I thought it would be best to
go visit and learn from the most
vociferous and vigilant critics we had
at that time which were Henry Spira head
of animal rights international and Peter
Singer who wrote the book Animal
Liberation which is considered the
modern treatise about animal rights you
know I read Peters book to prepare I try
to get into his mindset and I have to
admit
tough I'm not becoming a vegan my
company wasn't going that way but I
really thought we can learn a lot and so
I set up a breakfast meeting in New York
City and I remember sitting down getting
ready and I decided you know I'm not
gonna order my favorites which is you
know bacon and sausage and eggs and I'm
just gonna stick to the pastries but I
have to admit I was waiting for the
adversarial discussion to happen and it
never did Henry and Peter were just
gracious they were caring they were
smart they asked good questions I told
them about how working on animal welfare
is very tough for McDonald's because our
direct suppliers they only make meat
patties the animals are three or four
steps you know removed from our
influence and they were very empathetic
and while we were so directly opposed in
terms of the missions of our
organizations I thought that I'd learned
a lot and best of all they gave me a
terrific recommendation and that is they
said you should work with dr. Temple
Grandin now I didn't know her at the
time but I tell you she's the most
renowned expert then and now on animal
behavior and she knows how animals move
and how they should react in facilities
so I end up meeting her and you know
she's the very best type of critic in a
sense that she is loves the animals
wants to protect them but she also
understands the reality of the meat
business and I'll always remember I had
never been to a slaughterhouse you know
in my life and so I go with her for my
first trip I didn't know what to expect
and we find that the animal handlers
have electric prods in their hand and
are basically zapping almost every
animal in the facility you know we're
both appalled she's jumping up and down
you'd have to know where she's saying
this can't be this isn't right we could
use flags we could use plastic bags we
could redesign the Corral's for natural
behavior while I set up temple with our
suppliers to set up standards and
guidelines and ways to measure her ideas
of implementing animal welfare we did
this for the neck
two to five years and it all got
integrated it all got enforced by the
way two of MacDonald suppliers lost
business because they didn't meet our
standards and best of all all these
standards ended up scaling to the entire
industry and no more zapping of those
animals now what about issues that were
blamed for elsewhere like deforestation
you know an issue I always thought
policymakers and government that's their
role never thought it would end up like
in my lab if I remember in early April
2006 I opened up my blackberry and I'm
reading about Greenpeace campaigners
showing up in the UK by the dozens
dressed as chickens having breakfast at
McDonald's and chaining themselves to
the chairs and tables so they got a lot
of attention including mine and I was
wondering if their report that they had
just released it was called eating up
the Amazon and by the way soy is a key
ingredient for chicken feed and that's
the connection
to McDonald's so I called my trusted
friends at the World Wildlife Fund I
called Conservation International and I
still soon learned that the Greenpeace
report was accurate so I gathered
internal support and I always remember
next day after that campaign I called
him up and I said we agree with you and
I said how about working together so
three days later miraculously for people
from McDonald's for people from
Greenpeace for meeting in the London
Heathrow Airport and I have to say the
first hour was shaky there wasn't a
whole lot of trust in the room but it
seemed like everything came together
because each of us wanted to save the
Amazon and during our discussions you
couldn't really tell I don't think who
was from Greenpeace and who was from
McDonald's so one of the best things we
did is we traveled with them for nine
days on a trip through the Amazon on the
Greenpeace airplane on the Greenpeace
you know boat
and I'll always remember imagine
traveling hundreds of miles west of
Manaus the capital city of the Amazon
and it's so pristine beauty it's there's
no man-made structures there's no roads
not one wire in that one house you would
travel east of Manaus and you would see
the blatant rainforest destruction so
this very unlikely collaboration
produced outstanding results by working
together we recruited over a dozen other
retailers and suppliers for the same
cause and by the way within three months
a moratorium on these clear-cutting
practices were announced by the industry
and Greenpeace themselves declared it as
a spectacular drop and deforestation and
it's been in effect ever since
now you think these types of
collaborations that I've described would
be commonplace today but they're not
yeah when organizations are battered the
common response is to deny and push back
put out some sort of lame statement and
no progress is made at all I say the
alternative is really powerful I mean
it's not gonna fix every problem and
there's more to do for sure but this
idea of working with critics and trying
to do more good for society that
actually is good for business
believe me it's possible but it starts
with the idea that you need to assume
the best intentions of your critics just
like you have the best intentions and
then secondly you need to look past a
lot of these tactics I admit I do not
like a lot of the tactics used on my
company but instead focus on what the
truth is what's the right thing to do
what's the science what's the facts and
lastly you know I would say give the
critics the keys show them the back room
bring them there don't hide the details
because if you want allies and support
you need to be open and transparent now
whether you're corporate suits whether
you're a tree
I say the next time that you're
criticize reach out listen learn you'll
become better your organization will
become better and you might make some
good friends along the way thank you
[Applause]